regardez ce nouveau PC gaming il y a
3900 €, c'est le rogue strict car 16 il
est super joli et que ça bande lettre
qu'on va retrouver ici légèrement sur le
côté ici mais également à l'arrière
au-dessus de la grille de ventilation et
on a le logo rock qui est illuminé ici
on a ici un très joli écran mini LED
c'est du 16 pouces résolution
qHD c'est une Dali PS et qui va jusqu'à
un tour de rafraîchissement de 240 Hertz
on a également un clavier rétroéclairer
RGB et surtout beaucoup de performances
puisqu'on se parler c'est de Intel Core
inox c'est de la 13e génération avec 16
Go de RAM graphique dédié et jusqu'à 64
Go de RAM et vous montez également
jusqu'à 2 Tera au niveau du stockage en
terme de connectique on va voir le port
pour venir se recharger présage du 45 du
HDMI 2.1 2 prise USB C qui serviront
également à venir se recharger ça c'est
cool en DisplayPort aussi une prise jack
sans oublier deux prises en USBA ici
vous avez un ordinateur gaming
extrêmement complet extrêmement
performant qui sera pas foufou au niveau
de l'autonomie mais ça je vous en parle
sur Youtube et je vous dis tout dans mon
test qui va arriver très prochainement
qui peut être déjà arrivé allez savoir
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu un PC dédié
gaming et est-ce qu'une machine comme
celle-là a un tout petit peu moins de
3900 euros et vous tenter oui non quoi
comment marquer moi ça bien évidemment
dans les commentaires